so thank you burner for a great lecture
interesting as always and maybe also
some questions from out here we have
some in the back just raise your hands
and Rebecca and I will get to you and
try to speak loud and put it quite
shortly yes please hi yes you've talked
about joining ideologies concepts in an
objective stage and there's been some
dispute over most of these ideologies or
concepts and even the objective stage
itself as to how accurate they may be I
do see a lot of the fusion Anna Anna
maybe a composition existing within each
perception with each within each
subjectivity and I see a challenge of
bringing those together when you talk
about futures and prospects relating to
these subjective views how important do
you see the aspect of optimism or to use
a boulder word faith optimism a first my
argument is not about subjective
monument is about for 35 years now I've
trying to do the Anthropology of a
modern and to try to understand how the
same people were multiplied the link
their linkage between humans and
non-human to an extraordinary degree to
the point of being coextensive with a
planet had a philosophy of their own
philosophy of science first but then a
general philosophy of a greater and
greater disconnect between subjectivity
and objectivity okay so that's my
paradigm I mean my agenda I try to
understand how the same people can live
with two completely different theory and
this is why several whites of all where
the forked tongues because they always
did something entirely different from
what happened
now this situation is now finished
because of ecological crisis the
disconnect at least the disconnect is
recognized and I think the Copenhagen
event was so interesting for that it's
the end of a certain idea about the
disconnect so it's not subjective
argument now I mean this is subjective
it is constructed I hope it's well
composed but it's not about subjectivity
so what I'm interested here is in the
shift to try to get at your quaint I
mean to talk about optimism and
pessimism would be a bit mood I mean
when you read Lovelock he says Gaius
carrying capacity is three hundred
millions and he never says how do you
move from 300 for eight or nine billions
to three hundred millions so is love
love a pessimist an optimist Gaia
doesn't seem to be as he says you cannot
win against gaya we are in war and we
lose if we win and we lose if we gave
now Lovelock is clearly not an optimist
in that sense so I'm not I'm less
interested in optimism and pessimism and
what does it mean to have shifted from
the future which was always hyped in
some sort of sense even when he was
dystopia it was hype to prospect and I
think that that's the switch I'm trying
to to get and for some strange reason
I'm sure lots of people would disagree I
see avatar to leave a film as a very
clear symptom of that shift remember the
last I mean I don't know if that's you
have you seen avatar you probably the
only one in this room have nothing but I
won't ask I won't ask but the last the
last image is quite amazing in terms of
optimism and pessimism because you see
the front line is withdrawing the
withdrawal from the planet I think is a
very powerful indication that something
is changing in the very definition of
what it is to be optimists and
pessimists to be optimists and
pessimists when where the future is not
the same thing has to be optimists and
pessimists when we are now facing
suspect things to come and actually the
very interesting features of guys
actually it comes at us it comes at us
that it doesn't look even at us so it's
a very different type of anthropology
necessary to absorb gaya Smith in my
view I hope I sort of them tiptoed
around your question please
okay thank you listen oh yes no song
okay I have a very very simple question
actually I would like to know a little
bit more about the difference between
constructivism and composed city vision
you said something in the beginning
about composite of ism having kind of an
aesthetic run to it or associations to
it is that were you driving I mean what
would be the exact difference between
the notional constructivism that you
have explored earlier and that you
mentioned sometimes today too and this
well I don't know if it's entirely new
but Jimmy new notion of calm positivism
first it's a simple but I think in the
field of which is my original field of
science studies we tried everything run
construction and always fail so to speak
because construction whatever I mean
even if you extract yourself from social
construction remains taken always in is
it true or is it constructed and there
is no way out of it so this is why maybe
maybe I will fade with composition but I
know that is the same argument which is
can we shift the discussion between
construct is it true or is it
constructed which works for no practice
especially not for scientific practice
of course not technology and so on to
the question is it well or badly
constructed a well or badly composed but
I think very reason is the one you
mentioned which is that composition as a
nice aesthetic aspect of it and I'm very
interested actually now in the link
between the whole ecological discussion
science studies and aesthetics because I
think a lot of e a lot of those question
are also aesthetic I mean cosmos after
all is an aesthetic term even in the
Greek it means a well organized or well
composed well against well a very strong
composition is value in the very notion
of cosmos so I think composition might
given a different flavor than counts
traction are also because i have used
construction so much and and always
having to discuss with people yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but is it true or is it
constructed and no wait wait it's not
recognize it welcome but it works for
technology doesn't work so well for
science and so on so this is I'm trying
composition I might feel of course but
being able to feel is what is good in
those two terms a well-constructed
things can fail auto why not let's let
the key thing hello thank you for your
talk one thing I'm a little confused
about is how we negotiate the politics
of ambiguity the polit the politics of
ambiguity by which I mean we have in the
Climategate the idea that there's no
absolute truth but this this has been
using a kind of reactionary way to make
people very apathetic and they can't
really go forward but at one point we
have to deal with some kind of hierarchy
of truths for example technological
choice choosing a windmill versus a jet
fighter this is the kind of practical
choices sweden's have to deal with in
terms of their technology policies so
how do we embrace an idea of truth
without falling into this the problems
that you've dealt with in your research
absolutism and I'm also wondering if
your your metaphor for the backward
versus the forward is just another way
of bringing up the truth the idea of a
truth which admittedly is subjective
without using the word truth it seems
that the way you use the word the this
metaphor of moving backward and looking
backward with when you move backward or
not there seems to be something in that
that seems to be related to the old idea
of what what a truth is you see I mean
on the one hand there's the classic
problem that people like wallerstein
talk about is that you know you can't go
too far with the idea of the absolute
truth but if you engage in relativism
that's demobilizing people become
apathetic so I'm wondering if this
you know we should salvage part of the
Martin modernists project because would
I see very very practically as someone
in the university's a lot of people are
very apathetic because they they have
been affected by a postmodern ambiguity
so the ambiguity which at one point it
became critical becomes less critical
well that's that's a quite important
question that the way I get into that
but not in this paper except very brief
illusion is that the vm big booty of
action may be much much in the french
scene which is quite interesting in that
respect is around with a notion of
precautionary principle because quick
the precautionary principle which you
might not know that but in its in the
french constitution it has been in
certain in french constitution which is
very odd because the french harsh
modernist but President Chirac for some
strange reason no one understood did
absolutely nothing for eight years exit
bad thing which is extremely surprising
and the interesting thing of the
precautionary principle is that it sort
of make legal and institutionalize
exactly the ambiguity you are talking
about which is energy to act is not
actually depending on knowing and that's
a very interesting thing and it's a
complete surprise to the French it was
created actually very the reason why it
was so important while doing the tainted
blood scandal because during the whole
tainted blame blood scandal the French
partridges said as long as we are not
sure we don't stop so for the first time
people realized when that the definition
of action was always based on the notion
of knowledge when you know you act when
you don't know you don't act and the
idea of acting while you don't know
that's exactly what is based weather
what is built on the very interesting
idea of precautionary principle so to
come back to the Climategate an
application of a precautionary principle
would in my view have helped use the
ambiguity you talking about by saying we
don't know
and we vote the laws of nature the laws
of nature artists were set of action
which is now necessary to bend the trend
as we said in Copenhagen is not based on
absolute knowledge it's based on
precautionary principle and then you
could have some so of course the very
very important question you raise is
that if we don't know we are stuck we
are demobilized i think is the word you
use right and i think that it's a very
odd definition of action because black
action is I mean I'm completely doing
here I'm complete pragmatist here the
pragmatist tradition is precisely you
don't know this you act and you learn of
a consequence of your action and you
could perfectly have imagined a very day
I mean this is a scenario of course
completely invented by me but where the
skeptics why do you laugh when i select
we have a skeptic would have been
without force if we had say we don't
know there are lots of chances could you
I mean all those signs to the type of a
we decide that for next five years for
this is an undisputable undisputable end
of the discussion for five years the
entropy laws of nature the entropic
cause of climate time global warming is
decided upon so and I think that's where
the whole the whole interest of a
precautionary principle it gives back to
action a spring and energy which is not
based on knowledge you see what I mean
this mobilization is not linked to that
and I think of course none of our action
is based constantly on knowledge I mean
it would be only the friendship video
that but when you know when you act it's
only because you know and when you don't
know you don't act I mean this is a very
odd definition no one you would use it
for anything like marrying having kids
eating I mean we never use it except one
science and technology is invoked and
the great sanity of a principle of
precaution is that it brings back at
many other definition what it is to
hacked and mini spring for action then
waiting for the scientists to agree
which is rarer and rarer now because of
the number of lobbies producing spurious
Sciences on one hand I mean remember the
sea guide the cigarette cancer
connection but also because science and
technology have extended everywhere so
you can't expect now to have the notion
of mobilization and demobilization based
on knowledge not because we don't know
of course we know a lot but we know
matters of concern no longer matters of
fact or we know in the matters of
concern we're not in a matter-of-fact
way so the whole divided between what is
mobilization and what is demobilization
is being modified now I agree with the
second question I have to think of that
more because of course it will use the
trope of modernism quite a lot by moving
right that's what we meant and I think
I'll pass on that one thank you I have
two small questions the first one is
against the background of your attempt
to sort of depict a total social
structure ideology or whatever you might
call it which is a risky business of
course a risky business I mean to talk
about modernism and the modernists
exposes you to the risk of making a
little bit more precise who are you
talking about sometimes you seem to be
trying to grasp a whole kind of social
structure sometimes there is perhaps a
person behind I was wondering whether
you were thinking of harbor mass or
someone else who are you talking about
it seems there is a risk of making a
parody in fact of talking about entire
social
structures in this way and your your
talk was in some respects a little bit /
optical from that point of view I think
in talking about modernism my second
question is perhaps related to that and
that is how could you know it's a very
simple question how could you know that
being the world or whatever although
there is is discontinuous how do you
know how do I know yeah I don't think I
know well the first question is the
world of modernism I mean of course
dealing with modernism is always too big
but I've simplified in we have never
been modern to a very simple point which
is a is mother not not a social
structure not an event not a moment but
a certain way to divine science from
society so the divide the history of a
divided of the division between science
and society is my Shibboleth to describe
who is modern and with not matter so
more philosophically of course it can be
and that might be true grand jaws even
more grandiose when he is a whited
argument about the bifurcation of nature
basically everyone believes in the
primary secondary quality is mother
everyone is doubted everyone who doubts
it is not everyone who thinks varies we
go beyond is postmodern right I mean
these are little little test and then
you can try yourself it's it it's
actually quite nice it works sometimes
much time at work sometime doesn't work
to describe we have never been modern we
have never been on it so it's not a
moment in history it's not a set of
practice to have been modern without men
but the the practice of science would
have actually been able to distinguish
to humans and nonhumans so but now there
is a much better way to define it which
is to use the scholars argument because
de skoura anthropology's much
much more solidly established in mine
and it's based on very very large on
ethnographic latuda probably this desk
or I'll we call it naturalism is that
for the European it's based on
philosophy of science and for the others
it's based on ethnography so there is a
slight problem with this cause an
argument as you know no one has ever
been able to define a moment where we
wear modern or we stop to be so we have
never been modern but solve the question
but we believe we were or sometimes we
believe we were and actually the Holy
story of them the rare moment when you
can pinpoint those where modern believe
they were modern begins very interesting
and there is now a whole little tumblr
now on the other question which is of
course the metaphysical question so I
mean it's not based on knowledge here
again I will iron Whitehead because
remember whited argument is that the
bifurcation of nature's begins somewhere
between the 17th century big block
that's it I mean it's Galileo's who make
it a technical things which lock make it
a philosophical argument and for whited
it stops with gems physically I mean
James is one that closed were counted is
opened by rock and white it begins to
define event and it's with event
basically that's what I booted to buy
this notion of discontinuity the only
thing I add to the argument of whited is
its political dimension which whited was
no interest has no interest in politics
it's clear that when you add the notion
of continuity of the laws of nature you
establish a polity and a large part of
what we did in science studies was to
show the connection between the
definition of matter and the definitive
purity very early on I mean 30 years ago
in the first work of the 17th century
hops of course so there is a very
interesting connection which white it
doesn't do between the defen of what is
the polity in which we we all are humans
non-human cetera and the definition of
that scientists philosophers of science
give of
so this is where I put my little finger
there and say okay if we have ability
that organized the continuity so well
but it's already there it doesn't have
to be composed ninety percent of the
political process is moot because we are
already assembled we are already
composed you see the point and that's
where of course we didn't it was not so
interesting before the ecological crisis
but when the ecology coal prices begin
and people begin to say well save the
whales or save a tuna fish the red tuna
30 never read Torah then we begin to
realize that this organization of all
the species was a composition even when
there was very interesting a meeting and
Paris last week on biodiversity even the
very notion of biodiversity the
composition is the argument now because
every species begins to have also its
Lobby so we have a double composition
that of ecosystem and that of polity so
everywhere they are little there are
little disconnections where political
process enter into the differential what
nature is and that's where that's how I
know I know
the discontinuity of all beings but if I
want to talk about all beings I've
metaphysician i will rely on white it
now if I want to talk about political
ecology I would be on safer ground and
say okay well why is mr. sarkozy into
the question of tuna fish why when you
begin to look at naturals I found
recently nettles where is the whole
European lobby around nettles is it
natural or tea this thing little you
have natural to run here okay well it
has a lobby believe it or not lateral
naturals advil lobby so even nettle
which I thought was really I mean little
not very interesting matters of fact is
becoming under matters of concern when I
was doing an exhibition making things
public I asked Laura and Destin she said
we have to have the last matter of fact
celebrated in two eggs into your
exhibition and I told when it Dustin
with the greatest toy in the science
well found one a good one a good last
matter of fact the undisputable
uninteresting unconnected and
politicized fact a nature since she is
very good and very good estonian every
time she had one she found connections
she found bush modern connection we
tried rocks and of course the whole of
geology games in and at the end we had
an empty box we couldn't find the last
undisputable uninteresting and
historical and anthropological matter of
fact the one you eat you know what sorry
the one you will you could bump on it
and it will resist without any sort of
interesting connections I mean bill it's
very interesting because below here you
have another it's called the networks of
innovation it's actually a marvelous
exhibition completely actor network by
the way and again I mean every single
element of noble history spread in all
sort of thing that's why I know this is
a proper parody though I'm thank you
very much for a very interesting
presentation professor Latour I'm I find
it really interesting that you're worked
the past years has become more overt
really overtly political than before I
mean it's always been about politics and
the politics of science but it's moved
into more the cosmopolitan dimension and
coming into questions of how to compose
a better world for all of us and you've
written a lot about the domination and a
little bit also about the corollary of
domination which is subjugation but I
find it that reading your work a lot of
the times looking at sort of the
conceptualization of violence it's still
very much about being civilized it's in
this course a lot of the violence even
though you write about putting symmetry
between things in and subjects and
humans it's still when we look at
violence we never often I I believe feel
find it see the really messy ugly and
results of physical corporal violence
and we're looking at how to compose a
good common world to live in together
I'm really interested in if you are ever
thinking about tackling the subject of
physical violence of corporal violence
and of violence of humans against humans
of things against humans and so few mins
against things because I think it's kind
of key I think it's difficult to tiptoe
around this question if you want to
really get into the dirt of how to
compose the the common world and there's
a corollary to this I would also like to
ask you in your cosmopolitan
thinking there's this really sticky
tricky term of liberation how would that
come in liberation of people and
liberation of non people you too huge
question well attachment I mean there is
a disconnect what among the disconnect
I'm interested is the one between
emancipation and attachment so there was
in the great virtue and beauty of a
modernist risk front I mean even in this
fourth movement was of course
emancipation and it still is for masses
of people of course emancipation is
still the word but then we also have the
other word which is attachment so what
I'm interested is in the again i'm i'm
doing the entre policy of a modern I
mean there's a prime of limiting where
we are of course but I am answered this
question on someone and all of that is a
contradiction between those two schools
of the trope of emancipation and the one
of attachment now the one which is
associated with an emancipation is
critique and I've become I've become
very suspicious of a world critique and
I said the wrong time the critique has
run out of steam precisely because of
what i said about nitra and that has a
bearing on the sermon on the first
question which is why i don't insist
violence but first thanks because of
course i've been criticized for exactly
the opposite fig which is I brought
violence into the heart of a piece food
science and technology which is supposed
to be for heaven out of which we will
escape violence by and looting and
getting to finally matters of fact of
their that you like them or not and
again bumping on the table is very
important at this point so what I prefer
but I agree with is its small sort of a
what I agree with your criticism in so
in many ways I
yes I've not worked but i'm also very
suspicious of negativity this very
concept which has been invented there's
a beautiful book on web on the total
revolution by bell now I forgot it's
nothing so I'm very suspicious of the
ease with which the world quitting and
power and domination are you know it and
and get them but that's not what I meant
here I try to do that in reassembling
the subtle a large part of social
theories based on these two word
critique domination in power and I'm
suspicious of that for lots of reason
the main reason is that what can be
quickie cannot be composed and i think
that's that's more that's maybe the
argument which is sort of tried today
around 16 centenary which might be silly
but i read was great interest to the
book by which i didn't know i should
have known by stephen toolman on cosmic
budet because Cosmopolis which is a very
odd book a very interesting book which
has a very interesting valued ization of
mental model again with a very
interesting argument about the
Scientific Revolution between being in
the 16th century not in the 17th century
and the 17th century being a
counter-revolution so in all of his
argument and 16th century is big on
violence so the way I would answer your
question is when I found what the modern
fleet fled from and I said in this paper
I mean great entrepreneurial question is
what where they flee religious war
certainly I mean this religious war was
in two mins argument and now of course
we have a religious war we have a
scientific wall we have the ecology Cold
War soon to come and we have a usual
political work so I don't see my work as
being sanitized sanitized to the point
of not talking about war but I see war
being distributed I'm always suspicious
of when it's pointed that he has
violence and domination and here
what about here you see why is it it but
I think it's a fair criticism yeah yeah
it's a fair criticism not like the one
before on parody I mean I'm professor of
sociology and I tried to remember in my
education if we mentioned some time that
people have become modern or if
societies or the social have become
modern so to me the question about we
have never become more than at least as
a sociologist it's quite strange because
I could say the same about democracy we
have never been Democrats but we have
some kind of modern democracies it seems
to me that I know from your earlier
works that you have deconstructed
society but it seems to me now that yeah
yeah but I think you used the word at
least in the Swedish translation they
construct I'm not sure about it but but
but it seems to me that you deconstruct
society now and the argument or your
arguments here just are just created
because you they construct the social
that much but you start again to to put
it together of course it is a kind of
creativity but why should we the
construct society and the social not
much sometimes we need for a kind of
theoretical reasons to keep some
elements of society and they constructed
in some way I think you deny in some way
they
assistance of the social that's why you
created your problem no well
deconstructed is not the word I use I
mean deconstruct Vella it is enough
deconstruct and I published a
thousand-page book or I could crash on
precisely the question of why do we
still want to destroy and deconstruct
when everything has to be composed and
we constructed so I mean maybe this is a
Swedish translation I don't know but or
maybe the history of Swedish destruction
of Catholicism in the iphone
iconoclastic I know did I know too
little about you iconoclasm crisis or
even though i had the surprising runes
of having honorary degree given to me in
latin which I was very surprised so it's
not as nothing to do is deconstruction
and it has nothing to do with the limit
of a social actually if anything actor
network is a fabulous expansion of the
social to nonhumans so if we have done
something which is to fall sociologist
which was limited to the human it's now
expanded so you should thank me for
having expanded your domain quite a lot
and I defined sociology at the signs of
associations not over the social and the
reason why I doubt the notion of social
in social explanation is not because
it's bad it's because it has to be
refreshed so my only argument but in
another book not in this thing here we
assembling the social is the due date of
social explanation I just asked could
you sometimes let's say every five years
or every six years we knew the content
of what is used to explain something
else I mean there's a due date for your
goal to do it for frozen fishes I mean
let's have a due date for social
explanation that's by argument is okay
so that we don't keep saying sort
explain even after what you did it's bad
it's rots I mean it does all sort of a
bad thing now my third more serious
argument is but nature and society are
the two collectors in which we organize
the modern is Constitution but modernism
is a constitution it's an unreached
impact where you say okay these two two
collectors one is nature and one in
society now my sort of zeitgeist
argument is now with the ecological
crisis nature and society are not the
two collectors to which we can attach
our interpretation of what we live with
when when I have Monsieur Sarkozy voting
within some strands commission of
parliament but it would save the tuna
fish the red tuna and of course fail on
this promise so that I have a tuna fish
here and Mr Sarkozy ver attached to the
same network and the same Association I
don't want to have to say because I'm a
sociologist Sarkozy here in society and
this guy here which is a natural thing
the fish is there and in between there
is something that only silly people like
actor network various cross so if you
have to choose between the separation
and the association I photo via
association but my argument is it okay I
mean I give you quite a lot of of rams I
mean sociology is now able to follow
precisely the moment when the fish gets
into connection with the Elysee Palace
and we couldn't do that before and
actually you use the same argument in
your very exhibition below you connect
novel parliament with it's actually said
the actors in the network that's what we
did I mean also of these guys that's why
science theory is the best thing
invented and I think it should have a
Nobel Prize by the way for peace and
literature
yes thank you for your talk I have a
question about the political
significance of composition you say that
we have the political significance there
more concretely what you mean by
composition you say that we have you
know we should look back at the 16th
century and hannah arendt rise that it
would happen in the 16th century was
that we went from observation to
experiment when we discovered that the
Sun was not revolving around earth that
we couldn't trust our senses anymore but
could not trust our senses what we see
we have to start experimenting so that
when science went and experiencing am
doing experiment and the creature was
that we cannot know what we have not
ourselves made we cannot know what we
have not ourselves made so we have to
sort of dig into we must intervene into
nature and we cannot be sure the
skepticism that started with the current
zone now that principle that we cannot
know what we are not ourselves made one
good doggie that I started with in the
16th century has also been a very
important political principle those are
went into democracy we have to take part
in politics we have to do democracy
ourselves so that sort of the
emancipatory potential that started from
that principle now you seem to want to
go back to this idea observation and you
talk about the steth days and this is a
movement coming very strong in global
politics that we don't have to vote
anymore but we can observe there's an
aesthetics people saying that we cannot
have democracy on the global level
animal we cannot make it there and
that's why I want to ask you when you
talk about composition you move from to
aesthetics what does that mean precisely
I'm not sure I understand what where
they observe v I mean this is a very
beautiful question but where the
observation argument comes in because is
this what you you would associate with
composition because composition seems to
be a very active act of I mean it's
using music it's using diplomacy it's a
very active world if not I'm so I don't
know where the observation
get but you're a veteran factum argument
get very well with all the sort of
ecological argument I mean ecological
argument are very largely based on the
on the artificiality of this association
of nature's and human that we make it
seems to me I mean the idea it seemed to
move a large part of the ecological
critique is very rightly a critique of
the notion of wilderness of it via the
thing that we would just be outside of
so my argument i am i'm not trying to
get the gist of your question it seemed
to me that on the contrary everything
that says that we have to make the house
the acres in which we are is what
ecology is about and here i would throw
in I don't know if it's very popular in
Sweden but I think the work but Peter
shutter deck I don't know you pronounce
here in Sweden Peter's rhetoric work on
on sears and a habitat and artificial
construction and need your being the
artificial construction fits very well
the artificiality of a construction in
which we are is no longer a problem when
science technology and nature so to
speak up I've expanded our coextensive
as I misunderstood on tell you the
question or maybe art it's my knowledge
of a 16th century which is too poor
which is perfectly possible so it seems
to me that on the country see I try to
associate the great philosophical
tradition of pragmatism not only do we
but actually Littman I'm a great fan of
villip manner translated in in French
and and I did a whole exhibition and the
catalog making things public around lit
man's argument about what it is to build
the politics and it seemed to me that in
the Phantom public which is a very
little known book of Lipman where is a
magnificent artificiality of building
with phantom the democracy and
dependence Democratic the contrary to
what people say so
I associate Lippmann with the eye hook
up lipman on logitech if you want and
actually inverse show making things
public and in the catalog we did connect
this to great thinker together now in
your question there is the notion of
aesthetics but acidic is nothing bad is
not as nothing to do with observation
it's a practice and it's an experiment
and I I think it is one of the essential
experiment of building the space in
which we now reside politically and
actually in my school I'm quitting next
year- I actually a school of political
art precisely for this reason because
the way we we present of a problem is
not the one we have in political arena
on me know in science but in the
connection between art science and
politics the way we we present the prime
and that's what I think is so
interesting to reconnect with the 16th
century actually how do we represent the
thing with disagree with how do we we
present matters of concern I don't think
we can do that without the artists not
because we observe but because we are
practice and an experimental practices
do we very nicely show in expert in
Arthur's expand job mama I I think there
is a very interesting moment in
especially the echo all of this of
course is completely as we understood
predicated on vehicle at record prices
if you are like with former minister of
science in France crude Elega we did
with with the negation is I mean you
just go on French as usual but if you
are interested if you are sensitive to
the adorable crisis the artist as a way
to represent presented gain the primary
which are difficult to represent
politically unscientifically seems to be
an essential part of the argument and
that's why again composition as I said
to this gentleman for me is a nice word
that I'm maybe we'll discuss afterward
because I might have misunderstood where
the observation argument gets
and I thought I want to get in case I
made a mistake in my connotation of the
word composition and yeah I'm hendrick
earned someone for stock on resilience
center I'm studying urban ecologies and
the politics of the organization of
urban ecologies which is a good place to
start because everything is so composed
and unnatural in some ways at the same
time I've colleagues are doing excellent
research on a global scale and right in
the spot of the ecological crisis and so
my question is if we want to sensitize
as this dialogue on the ecological
crisis to that a lot of that knowledge
is composed as well how we know about
ecological crisis what kind of research
projects are important to engage in and
how do you do that kind of research and
because at the same time we have this
ecologic crisis also seems to drive this
idea of nature as out there in the sense
that it invest more and more money and
resources into sort of big science
project they're trying to establish
facts and not engage in matters of
concern so my question is it seems that
you are putting the argument that the
glory crisis is in a sense of big so
they will this nature this science
society divided will evaporate in front
of the psychological crisis but at the
same time I can see the tendencies how
it sort of you get more and more
resources on society investing in this
big time big science project so as a
young scholar I want to understand how
can I engage in these debates what are
the good kind of projects to sensitize
these debates to become more open to
this
research and the composition of
arguments that you argued for thank you
well first I'm sure I have no time to
visit the resin young center but i'll
come back to visit it because that's one
of my plan is to visit your Center like
the one in minikin and because I want to
be one in Paris so I need to get you
extra cheese so I'd rather ask you a
question that give you a question what
one Avengers anything on compositions of
course by the question of size which is
so difficult in the case of ecological
crisis itself to be composed so that
there is no nesting between the small
and the big because every discipline
every topic actually as a different
scale the tuna fish inhabits circuses it
is a palace in very different ways from
the h1n1 and of course volcano ash from
the student volcano so there is a whole
but this is also why the notion of
disconnect and is usually about the size
of it now it's not a contrast its
contrast it's not a position between
matters of fact and matters of concern
you don't for matters of fact two
methods concern by decreasing the
constraint by increasing the constraints
and I mean the book I wrote called
politics of nature is based although
it's not clearing the book on a lot of
field work we did in my Center at Lehman
and what I propose is that precisely we
we place the question of science and
politics by the question of how many
people how many agency do we connect and
can we make a hierarchy out of it you
know what I mean it's a very odd way to
answer your question but it means that
the matters of concern is not a sort of
addition of social science to the fact
defined by naturalist because that will
never work I work for many years with a
guy was the head of Kenya the wild
animal park called David Wilson and the
wilderness it was in charge of
wilderness and of course acting
constantly in order to maintain the
wilderness constantly changing so this
is a normal thing and we studied
accurate Easter did a very nice case
where a very which billionaire add both
large bit of land and surrounded with
with with Maria and in six months there
was no wildlife in it which was it is
why he developed the whole the whole
theory of parks outside park and it
clear but I mean this guy publishes
paper with Messiah farmers it's very
interesting case I mean it publishes
similar images is a ello mate rishon the
one who tried to get a measure the laws
of measure between entities and he's
also writing papers with Messiah which
is quite an interesting contribution and
it actually the book politics of nature
is dedicated to him
because I think he has found a solution
to that the questionnaire is which is
compass if we want to get into
composition we have to abandon the idea
of the divide between fact and value BTW
which is behind which is a sort of
popularized version of it bifurcation of
nature not not to politicise the fact
that you ask a completely different a
question which are completely a diagonal
to that which is the two tasks anyway I
mean you can read the book is I'm not
going to summarize a book it's bad you I
don't want to ask your to answer your
question because I like we need to get
to see what sort of study you do invite
me to your centers and i would love to
comment on the studies and try and I try
to borrow your research protocol for my
own purposes if it's okay with you it's
not that I want to avoid a Daedra
question is that that's the really
interesting question our empirical and I
don't want to preempt them too fast
these are really serious question yeah
thank you very much for reassembling
some some of our ideas about human
agency it seems to me that part of your
cosmopolitan and your head many is
partly also humanist manifesto in some
ways in that when you kind of expand a
accident network from the social also
into the human sciences one of the
things you're doing is that you're
providing a renaissance for
representation representation that is
and for a novel focused on plants drafts
regulations and for aesthetic judgments
and so my question to you is will you
agree that to some extent this is a way
of bringing advent networks from the
technical and social party back to the
human through emphasizing agency and
plans
and composition to some extent to great
reach them I'm not completely sure I got
the question though so I agree with
having plans and humans it seems to me
that your focus on composition it makes
a greater place or more place for
studying and working and looking at
human plans intentions regulations
aesthetic judgments to bring human
sciences into the social and technical
sciences all to reconnect the human with
the social and the technical well I'm
not sure maybe I'm too tired but the
question is agency he is to be
redistributed and the divide between
type of agencies I mean this is a
discussion we had in science study for
many years when Max Weber says when the
bicycle falls down it's not anything
social but when the cyclist stops at a
sign its social I disagree and I think
trevor pinch disagree and lots of other
people disagree and say the bicycle
itself a making of a bicycle every
single aspect of it is association which
have been in which agency is to be
distributed for out so and i said here
more the question of the invention of a
inanimate is what is to be studied
anthropologically and not the remnant of
animism into rational thinking but
especially when you are yourself
studying science is to our product
making agencies periphery I mean this is
what is so surprising when you study
so-called reductionist biologists the
proliferation of extra extra
proliferation of agencies for the
laboratory of course laboratory is a
great product producers of multiple ad
agencies so this is disconnect between
the praxis of proliferation agencies and
oh no no no no there is a strict
difference between bicycles and
bicyclist is what my objective study why
agencies being distributed in very
interesting way
and yet we are not supposed to be
distributed that's a puzzle and I add a
little urgency to be special by saying
politically it's very odd to live with
the ecological crisis with the
definition of agencies which dates back
from the time of mother which never
happened in addition that's what my
answer is thank you very much